seit die astronauten der mission apollo
17 am 19
dezember 1972 zurück zur erde kam gab es
keine bemannte mondlandung mehr trotzdem
plant die esa bis 2030 die erste
siedlung auf dem mond mit sechs bis zehn
bewohnerinnen und bewohnern bis 2040
sollen 100 menschen dort wohnen und
arbeiten zehn jahre später bereits 1000
doch ist das überhaupt möglich gibt es
genug wasser und woher soll der
sauerstoff kommen tricks um
science-fiction hier gibt es jeden tag
faszinierendes seines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's sicher ist zumindest dass an
den polen des mondes tonnenweise
wassereis im boden lagert die indische
mondsonde chandrayaan-1 entdeckte dort
vor knapp zehn jahren mehr als 40 grad
die so tief sind dass das eis vor der
sonneneinstrahlung geschützt ist
inzwischen machten us forscher und
forscherinnen den beweis dass es sich
wirklich um wasser und kein anderes
gefrorenes material handelt das mit
mondgestein vermischt ist aber auch
sonst ist der mond keineswegs so
staubtrocken wie früher angenommen
das vulkangestein im mantel des mondes
enthält ebenfalls wasser wobei jedoch
weiter unklar bleibt woher es stammt
damit wäre das problem des wassers
zumindest halbwegs vom tisch man müsste
nur einen weg finden das eis zu
schmelzen um es trinkt wahr zu machen
schwieriger wird die gewinnung von
sauerstoff zum atmen
man könnte das wasser mittels
elektrolyse in seine chemischen
bestandteile sauerstoff wasserstoff
spalten
jedoch ist hierbei die frage ob man das
wertvolle trinkwasser dafür verbrauchen
sollte eine bessere option wäre es die
einzige substanz zu verwenden die auf
dem mond im überfluss vorhanden ist das
mondgestein reguliert das aus sauerstoff
haltigen mineralien sogenannten oxiden
besteht die wissenschaftler kennen die
zusammensetzung von reguliert aus der
untersuchung der proben die ihnen den
60er und 70er jahren vom mond zur erde
gebracht wurden um sauerstoff aus diesem
gestein zu gewinnen testet die nasa
bereits ein system bei dem das gestein
von einem kleinen rover auf einer rampe
geschoben und zerkleinert wird
anschließend wird es von oben in einen
reaktor gefüllt der das gestein zu
sauerstoff verarbeiten kann
dieser reaktor soll bis zu 660 kilogramm
sauerstoff pro jahr liefern das wäre
genug für zwei astronauten
bis jetzt scheint die chemie in diesem
test reaktor zu funktionieren die
techniker und technikerinnen haben wir
doch mit anderen problemen zu kämpfen
denn der mondstaub ist durch den
sonnenwind elektromagnetisch aufgeladen
wenn er aufgewirbelt wird klebt er
überall und kann durch die geringen
schwerkraft nicht richtig durch den
trichter rieseln die techniker und
technikerinnen versuchen nun das
reguliert einzusaugen oder den trichter
vibrieren zu lassen das reguliert könnte
weiterhin für den bau von unterkünften
auf dem mond dienen auch hier laufen
bereits tests mit synthetischen
mondstaub der dem original sehr nahe
kommt spezialisten des deutschen luft
und raumfahrtzentrums dlr versuchen
bereits aus diesem staub eine art
ziegelstein herzustellen dafür bündeln
sie das sonnenlicht mit 159 spiegeln und
erhitzen damit das material auf 1100
grad wodurch es anschließend schmilzt
und später beim abkühlen einen festen
stein bildet so ist zumindest die idee
doch so einfach wie es in der theorie
klingt ist es nicht die einzelnen
bestandteile des materials verhalten
sich in der hitze sehr unterschiedlich
manche mineralien schmelzen früher
manche erst später dadurch werden die
steine nicht zu einer gleichmäßigen
struktur gebacken und zerbrechen dadurch
oft bei belastung jedoch macht das dlr
große fortschritte und hat mittlerweile
eine sehr solide rezeptur die die steine
halten lässt ob eine besiedelung des
mondes möglich ist und wann damit zu
rechnen ist bleibt trotz allen
fortschritts noch unklar
es gilt weitere faktoren zu beachten wie
beispielsweise die gewinnung von nahrung
stark schwankende temperaturen mit
temperatur sprüngen von mindestens 60
grad die gefahr der kosmischen strahlung
und nicht zuletzt die geringen
schwerkraft auf dem mond die auf dauer
probleme bereiten könnte der mond hat
jedoch noch etwas anderes zu bieten als
eventuellen lebensraum für uns menschen
er ist eine riesige energiequelle als
besonders begehrenswert gilt das gas
helium-3 das durch sonnenwinde zum mond
gelangt ist und sich im mondstaub
abgelagert hat das gilt als sehr guter
brennstoff nach berechnung von physikern
und flüssigeren könnte es auf dem mond
eine million tonnen davon geben das wäre
genug um unsere erde achtung tausende
von jahren mit strom versorgen
jeff bezos der amazon gründer und
derzeit reichster mensch der welt will
den mond mit seinem raumfahrtunternehmen
blue origin früher oder später sogar als
produktionsstandort nutzen und dort
schwer industrie ansiedeln die mit
sonnenenergie betrieben wird doch es
gibt noch eine andere frage
und die liebt nicht so ganz auf der hand
wenn die menschheit den weltraum erobern
will
oder sogar die erde verlassen muss würde
die energie auf der erde überhaupt
ausreichen um uns alle in den weltraum
zu bringen eine frage die der kanal
neugier zone in diesem video beantwortet
dafür wie immer drauf klicken und den
kanal unbedingt abonnieren ist einfach
der hammer
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran